c'est un scoop qui s'affichait la une et
qui sort demain comme nous vous
dévoilons en exclusivité ce soir une
information qui risque de faire beaucoup
parler
selon le magazine public jean dujardin
et sa compagne nathalie péchalat aurait
décidé de fuir à la france pour se
réfugier en suisse
une décision que le couple aurait
mûrement réfléchie et qui ferait écho au
poste instagram publié par jean dujardin
il ya quelques jours
en pleine polémique autour du film
j'accuse dans lequel il tient le rôle
titre
je me casse ça pue dans ce pays un
message violent que le comédien avait
choisi d'effacer quelques minutes plus
tard si après le succès de the artist
jean dujardin s'était déjà installée
partiellement aux états unis avant de
finalement revenir aujourd'hui son choix
semble directement liée à la polémique
polanski et l'acteur n'est pas la
première célébrité à faire ses valises
loin de l'hexagone
on se souvient par exemple de plusieurs
personnalités qui pour des raisons
parfois un peu différente avait choisi
de prendre leurs distances avec la
france comme johnny hallyday gérard
depardieu arthur ou encore charles
aznavour alors comprenez vous les stars
qui quitte la france
alors merci à mettre de la suisse d'être
avec nous merci beaucoup avocat
fiscaliste vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi de plus en plus d'artistes
quitte la france vous donc c'est un
scoop signé public je vous le dis le 29
février dernier donc jean dujardin posté
un message sur instagram où il a annoncé
vouloir quitter la france je me casse ça
pue dans ce pays vous croyez que c'était
une vanne et selon le magazine public
tout ça n'avait rien d'une boutade
alors est ce que vous comprenez ces
stars qui quitte la france passe
aujourd'hui jean dujardin
voilà moi j'ai une tendresse
particulière pour lui je l'aimé
énormément il le sait et c'est récurrent
du jardin je ne pense pas que ce soit
des questions fiscales
je pense que c'est plus qu'il a été très
touché par tout ce qui s'est passé et ce
autour du film j'accuse là je parle
d'autres stars aussi y en a plein qui
ont quitté la france il ya dany boon
voilà qui l'a dit pour des raisons
fiscales voilà il ya des ânes à d'autres
font pas ni exactement
yahia d'autres il ya des animateurs la
france est vraiment que tu en penses
quoi naturellement je vais pas dire ils
ont raison je suis un peu triste quand
il quitte la france moi j'aime la france
mais nous on peut pas quitter la france
par exemple n'a pas le choix on obligé
de rester là on paye nos impôts
eux ils le problème c'est toujours
pareil où ils gagnent leur argent ils le
gagnent avec les français c'est nous qui
allons voir leurs films au cinéma c'est
nous qui monte en onze balles dans une
place de ciné et après dès qu'ils ont
ramassé le peuple pactole ils prennent
les sous il se barre avec le soudan a
ordonné sans fond faut rester bas
bernard alors respectons on peut pas
dire ça répond banon tout ce que tu
gagnes en france tu le payes fiscalement
en france j'étais huissier de justice
il ya quelques années je peux te dire ça
c'est très important n'est ce pas
monsieur le fiscaliste mais quand une
habitante il habite plus de six mois tu
n'habites façon quand tu t'en vas six
mois difficiles mais c'est le fiscaliste
quand on s'en va six mois du territoire
français on ne paye ses impôts en france
pas du tout pas du tout alors
respectivement alors ont-elles qui a
raison très bien il ya un principe de
fiscalité française et de fiscalité
internationale qui est la taxation au
lieu de l'exercice d'activités vatican
mais cette taxation se fait souvent un
taux réduit de par les accords fiscaux
international à dakar comptant là
l'exemple d'un artiste qui irait vivre à
l'étranger
bien sûr quand ils vont des dix quand il
touche c'est ont caché sur des places de
cinéma des tournages genre de chose il
va payer de l'impôt en france il y aura
une retenue à la source qui est le plus
souvent plafonnée à 15%
donc effectivement entre 15
45 plus des charges sociales on peut
arriver très très vite à 70% il ya un
gap
donc effectivement il ya souvent un
ras-le-bol fiscale il ya un effet
psychologique ce que des artistes et
sportifs qui peut la france ils sont
souvent un pandémique cat s avec la
fiscalité puisque alors il ya une
beaucoup d'argent très très vite
souvent c'est mal déclaré donc il ya des
contrôles fiscaux même florent pagny on
avait fait une chance y ont donc commis
sont échaudés par sa pipe la france
alors mettre des astuces on a fait un
petit calcul on appris hier par exemple
un très grand acteur ou un très grand
chanteur voilà qui gagnerait 10 millions
d'euros par an c'est vrai pour les
grands grands oui voilà pour les mois je
vous dis ouais le top va regarder s'il
paye ses impôts en france
il lui restera 4 à 6 millions après
impôts s'il part dans un autre pays
impôts français automatique 8,5 millions
d'euros après impôts ça veut dire qu'ils
gagnent à peu près 4 millions - voilà
quatre millions d'euros par an s'il paye
ses impôts en suisse
forfait c'est il lui restera 7,5
millions d'euros après impôts quand je
vous donne quand je vous donne mine de
rien c'est un fonds et à vous aussi
téléspectateurs est ce que vous
comprenez que les gens qui gagnent
énormément d'argent puisse quitter la
france jean-michel oui moi je suis
franchement très bonne oui moi si
j'avais beaucoup d'argent n'est pas mais
je peux très bien comprendre à vous en
avez quand même beaucoup je suis pas
[ __ ] vous gagnez bien voyons
évidemment mais je suis pas jusqu'en fin
de l'été que je parle de time est un jeu
de rôle choses comme ça je suis pas
putté ménard qu'un autre comme pour les
bagarres j'aimerais bien aussi mais je
me dis tout le temps 10e et d'hygiène
bagarre je réagis je je je m'interposer
non je suis un peu je suis un peu lâché
je m'en excuse
et s'il y avait beaucoup d'argent pêche
près comme les autres j'essaierai d'en
garder le maximum pour moi j'essaye
d'échapper un peu sans être dans
l'illégalité
ce qu'ils font est pas illégal ces
débats vous comprenez dany boon qui a
quitté la france voilà qui est parti aux
états unis
dany boon vous comprenez moi franchement
je ne sais pas si le répète je pense que
je partirai aussi il faudrait des fonds
tous les joueurs de tennis par tous et
de fonction soit détachables candidats
j'avais un mélange bien ils gagnent leur
argent partout dans le monde est
d'accord il a raison oui j'ai bien on
dit du jardin vous faut pas de
bisounours j'ai dit oui il en a marre de
la france il a été blessé comme part ça
ils partent jamais en biélorussie où
parce que c'est tout proche et qui peut
faire des achats vous avez remis
remettait l'animation tout à l'heure la
nouvelle j'ai parlé j'ai parlé de paie
des impôts m'a dit non non c'est obligé
qui paye ses impôts en france alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cette animation
et il est domicilié way suisse ou dans
un autre pays d'accueil
il paye ses impôts dans un autre pays à
bath & body on suit bien il faut qu'il
ait raté ça que je suis venu retirer six
mois et un jour dans le pays
chez les règles sont un peu plus
compliquées chaque coin et 5 mai en
suisse et un nombre de jours mais par
exemple en angleterre c'est c'est d'un
critère de présence substantielle sur
trois ans ce genre de choses mais ce qui
est le plus important je reviens c'est
que c'est pas parce qu'on a quitté la
france qu'on ne paye plus d'impôt en
france il ya une polémique sur les
dirigeants d'entreprise il n'y a pas que
les artistes et des sportifs il pesant
macron avec lord et gilet jaune avait
dit les dirigeants des grandes boîtes
cac 40 doivent payer de l'impôt en
france
bien sûr les députés l'ont étendue à
beaucoup beaucoup de sociétés mais
depuis cette année les dirigeants de
grandes sociétés françaises
même s'ils vivent à l'étranger doivent
payer de l'impôt ensuite c'est quelque
chose qui existe
il paye pas qu'en ville d'oran famille
mulliez est ce sens pour les citer des
cas tout ce qu'on achète au chant machin
gens très riches a eu une fille sont en
belgique ou pas l'argent ils gagnent en
france
ils déclarent pas comme les français
lambda là on parle on parle des artistes
en berne alors est ce que moi je ne les
connais pas du tout ces gens là pour moi
doivent au contraire être solidaires les
impôts c'est de la redistribution
ils ont gagné énormément d'argent en
étant artiste en france on est fier
d'être français
on est certes mais aussi mais nous on
est français on doit payer des impôts
aider les plus pauvres en france ça sert
à ça les impôts donc si tous les riches
barre alors normand la fnac son parti
qui sont venus à arthur il est parti oui
et il est revenue oui alors il ya eu des
incitations à revenir sain je le
comprends il est en règle et revient le
gouvernement lui fait une sorte de
prorata de ce qu'ils auraient dû payer y
revient elle est en règle
là je comprends c'est bien de revenir
mais on devrait pas partir voilà il faut
pas fuir la france voit tombe bien car
sinon c'est du peu de faire du français
et ça fait mal au cul de payer 75 et ben
non
abbas
démago mais torres combien c'est très
démago ce que je dis mais torres combien
sur 10 millions voilà en france alors on
va dire j'ai dix millions en france un
niveau basket avec millions voilà 4 4
millions mais on exactement 4 millions
en france
et si vous partez en suisse il voudrait
cet ennemi mais le calcul est vite fait
alors non mais lequel on met vite fait à
bâtiment ils sont pas dans l'illégalité
pas dans la fraude fiscale c'est la
partie respecte leur résidence jeu
mêlant leurs voix
mais quand on commet une galère il vient
de se soigner là leurs enfants étudient
ici
elle n'aborde pas la seule chose que je
peux vous mettez moi voilà je me pose la
question et je me fais le porte parole
de ce que peuvent dire les gens devant
leur écran et je comprends ce qu'ils
peuvent dire ils peuvent se dire aussi
dany boon moi je suis désolé voilà dany
boon quand il a fait 22 millions
d'entrées avec les ch'tis sa fortune
parce que c'est là qu'il a fait sa
fortune il l'a fait avec les français
mais il paye en voilà non mais oui donc
dire qu'après il part après c'est ce que
l'on ose dire les gens moi je suis pas
contre lui ou pas je vous dis ce que
peuvent dire les gens ils disent c'est
nous qui avons fait sa fortune
donc forcément on aimerait bien voilà
qui reste et qui écrit nous n aurons pas
nous avons combien de disques en
patagonie en patagonie pas bon c'est
vrai il mais ils ont tous les riches
s'en vont c'est les classes moyennes qui
vont encore payer plus d'impôts dsk je
prends d'autres exemples vous l'aviez d
une fois vous vous aviez dit moi je
gagne de l'argent en france et c'est
tant mieux pour vous vous payez vous
rester en france mais vous partiriez
jamais à l'étranger mais ça s'est bien
occupé et bloqué ici
journée des marques dans l'année sur le
plan de l'éthique et de la réponse est
oui vous aurez à chevallier mieux bravo
mesdemoiselles massa mais si tous les
supers ils s'en vont alors qui va placer
sur ovi mail élément n'a pas tiqué
mandat on en a besoin des super-riches
désolé oui oui désolé je suis désolé
jean michel question who did you
monsieur là je dis bravo à gc un
chevalier blanc il a dit là il a des
valeurs un incroyable qu'il sait que
c'est tiré plein d'argent qui reste
l'enfant ce cancer est à jamais dans
cette maison que moi je me bats jean
michel a eu l'honnêteté de jabal booba
rêve aussi moi si j'étais très riche je
resterai toujours en france tout
simplement que je peux pas envisager de
vivre ailleurs mais un revanche dire les
riches s'en vont c'était moi je déteste
les collectifs comme ça non le le cadre
de dany boon n'est pas le même cas que
celui de jean dujardin dont étudiante
cas par cas d empalot driss omar sy vit
à los angeles
merci c'est tout c'est bernard les cas
sont là je dis qu'il faut arrêter il
faut arrêter quand même maintenant on
est dans une dynamique dans une société
très violente d' arrêter d'opposer les
riches avec les pauvres
lamentable tu deviens alors d'une
violence à tous les niveaux c'est
pénible
et tu crois que ces réponses qui peuvent
partir à l'étranger à dire je connais
ton cinoche habituel
alors moi je vais vous dire une chose
c'est quand même ces gens riches dont
vous parlez c'est quand même des
créateurs d'emplois ce sont des yeux
mouillés datura alors si il se barre est
vraiment et je rappelle encore une fois
de plus qu'ils payent leurs impôts en
france alors certes il ya des montages
de société 1 vous le savez sans doute
bien sûr qui arrange les choses sinon
gens là travaillent en france et payent
leurs impôts pour les iphone quand il
faut arrêter de faire des sociétés parce
que justement il ya des mécanismes anti
abus parce que les états unis puis à une
concurrence fiscale entre les états mais
il ya beaucoup on va parler des morts
comme ça j'aurais pas de problème
déontologique mais charles aznavour
s'est fait condamner match annoncé mon
ami
devant les oui mais s'est fait condamner
de première fois devant les tribunaux
parce qu'il est intercalé des sociétés
qui lorsqu'il faisait un concert en
france me touche c'est juste un petit
cachet et ctc seul mais la rondelle au
dar al iman bowie là il ya un arrêt de
doter le code général des impôts et dans
la plupart sur les droits d'auteur oui
eh ben on était taxée là pour le coup à
65% en france voilà on ne peut pas dire
qu'il payait pas ses impôts en france
mais parce que ces structures a été jugé
comme complètement juifs ici ajuste la
france est un des pays qui taxe le plus
c'est ça oui parce qu'il ya un cumul en
fait d'un pot en impôt sur le revenu on
a une certaine progressivité on a un
taux à 45%
voilà mais il ya en plus les charges
sociales il ya en plus la csg crds qui
est hybride entre la charges sociales et
l'impôt sur le derrière le moine donc on
peut arriver jusqu'à 70 75 % ça dans les
autres pays on n'a pas si vous d'accord
alors est ce que vous comprenez aussi
que des personnes très riches des
artistes n'en parle des artistes voilà
est-ce qu'ils fassent qui font des
montages financiers sont quitter la
france ou bien vous leur en voulait
aussi
non mais je pense qu'ils sont là pour
utiliser effectivement signé après on
sait tous que 70%
c'est beaucoup maintenant si on était à
35 % 45 cents maisons ne partirai pas la
position qui est effectivement on va
dire sur 10 millions il a quatre
millions trois millions c'est beaucoup
d'argent mais effectivement ça reste 70
% sur ses énormes qu'on vous prenne est
énorme et les trois quarts de travail ou
gagner je comprends que les matches y
compris à ce qui dit que c'est abusé 1
sur le parce qu'il ya des gens qui
disent que c'est confiscatoire
le problème vient de là c'est qu'un mec
qui gagne beaucoup d'argent on va lui
prendre 70 % c'est beaucoup trop
le monsieur le fiscaliste l'a dit on est
les champions du monde il n'y a pas
cherché sur internet chercher partout
y a pas un autre pays au monde à exercer
en direct le monde et plus d'impôts que
la france que ce soit en charge
patronale en taxes y a pas un autre pays
on est champions du monde les foudres et
champion du monde il ya une image tu
parle très bien dans les pins qui est
très riche qui travaillent toute l'année
de janvier à mi octobre et traille pour
l'état a passé le mur tonnes il commence
sa touche l'argentin cérétans ont parlé
de santé tout à l'heure et de tes
enfants et dl santé et cetera
si justement paie des impôts c'est pour
ça c'est pour que tout le monde ait
droit à la santé et au mans faut que
tout le monde sont soignées dans les
hôpitaux connaît de bonnes de bonnes
routes connaît d'une meilleure vie et
grâce à sa réserve
les sportifs sont soit mal sensible à
cet argument du tout confiscatoire parce
que eux ont toujours peur de faire des
carrières court bien sûr est un
footballeur il va jusqu'à 50 ans il ya
beaucoup d'ingénieurs et savoir dire il
a toujours ses désormais sur un chanteur
sont ils se disent je gagne beaucoup
d'argent mais si c'est pendant trois
quatre cinq dix ans devrait donc il
serait un peu mais je la notion de
matière fissile à toi avec vous
messieurs je perds la corde ou quand on
me dit il reste quatre millions avec un
français dans toute sa vie les touches
mal on est d'accord mais bon vivre il a
beau avoir peur mais quand il a touché 4
millions en une fois dans une année il a
beau avoir peur je suis d'accord je
comprends qu'ils aient peur mais si vous
prenez le salaire des françaises sur
toute une aile 4 millions il va te
falloir s'entendre pour les toucher et
vend pas mais c'est pas comparable
mais je ne divise pas je ne divise pas
c'est juste que le mec qui les 4
millions capper ouais bah moi j'attends
on a des mecs quart de mille balles ils
ont peur aussi voilà ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs comprenez oui à 60 des
gens comprennent les stars qui t'apprend
bravo donc c'est vraiment un large
majorité à bravo sur l'incroyable
cassation dalle oui est ce que les
classes moyennes aussi se font saigner
par le fisc donc bien sûr que les
français comprennent
on est tous comme ça on est tous dans le
même bateau donc ya pas que les riches
qui payent des impôts
il ya aussi les classes men qui sont
taxés à 50% c'est incroyable je
m'attendais pas taxées en fonction
on les comprend pas ce qui nous taxent
tellement qu'ils ont
ce soit